here are no frills scientifically backed
evidence-based ways to help you fall
asleep huge thanks to Mattress Firm for
sponsoring this video
don't eat too close to bedtime but if
you do eat focus on complex carbs you
want to avoid high fat protein meals as
they take a really long time to digest
and they can actually impact some of
your hormones like a rexin which can
keep you alert and not really sleepy
speaking of avoiding Foods before sleep
you want to avoid spicy foods not only
can they make you feel uncomfortable
because they can trigger symptoms of
acid reflux but they also raise your
core body temperature it's the exact
opposite thing of what your body's
trying to do in order to get to sleep
avoid studying TV phones other
activities the only thing that should
happen in bed is sleep and sex avoid
blame for not getting a good night's
sleep as this can only make the problem
worse know that humans have a distinct
chronotype based on their genetic code
that will select when sleep comes to
them naturally so you may fall asleep at
a completely different time than me I'm
a fan of naps but I'm talking about a
short nap early in the day when you
start making them longer than 30 minutes
or having them close to bedtime even
around 5 6 PM that's going to affect
your sleepiness hormone and make it
really hard to want to go to sleep at
night be wary of caffeine and I'm not
just talking about coffee there's
caffeine in tea sodas energy drinks
pre-workouts so ideally you want to be
consuming this caffeine before lunch in
fact if you like having a nap early in
the day consume the caffeine just before
your nap to get the most out of it but
caffeine close to bedtime is going to
want to make you pee in the middle of
the night make you wake up caffeine
actually also impacts your ability to
enter the Deep stages of sleep meaning
that you might get a full night's sleep
but not a restorative night's sleep
decrease blue light exposure you can do
this by getting the devices out of your
bedroom putting them on night shift mode
if you really need to use them or
perhaps using blue light blocking
glasses legit ones that actually work
because blue light will actually
decrease the production of melatonin
that sleepiness hormone we talked about
earlier help your body cool down by
lowering the thermostat Norm normally
when we start to get sleepy our body
temperature drops by a degree or two
this is incredibly important in the
bedroom to facilitate your body to feel
sleepy but it's usually done by sweating
and who wants to sleep in their own
sweat just lower the thermostat increase
light exposure early and throughout the
day open those curtains first thing even
on a cloudy day because the eye sends
signals to the super chiasmatic nuclei
which then sends signals to the pineal
gland in the brain and that helps
optimize sleep hormones even later that
night invest in your sleep gear I'm
specifically talking about your mattress
and this is individualized and will be
different for everybody because
depending on your sleep position your
medical conditions your body habitus
your size your shape you will have
different preferences so go to a store
try out different mattresses see what
works for you back to more tips in just
a second but first I want to talk to you
about Mattress Firm as a doctor I
obviously always recommend that my
patients get a good night's sleep but
that's more important than ever during
the holiday holidays in the chilly
winter months large family gatherings
company holiday parties and
get-togethers with friends who are back
in town are unfortunately ideal places
for the flu and colds to spread and one
of the best ways to allow your immune
system to fire on all cylinders is by
getting a good night's sleep every night
Mattress Firm strives to do just that
during their dream sember sale finding a
gift for better sleep is easier than
before you can get a king bed for the
price of a queen or a queen bed for the
price of a twin plus get a free
adjustable base with some purchases I
just got my new Sleepy's hybrid media
mattress for Mattress Firm and while I
so enjoy getting to sleep on it every
night I also really enjoyed having it
shipped right to my door in a convenient
box it made the process from buying the
mattress to sleeping on it so easy they
don't just have the largest selection of
mattresses though but also tons of
pillow sheets blankets and other
sleeping accessories like sleepy supima
cotton sheet set or this Coconut Bliss
pillow shop mattress firm's dream
December sale right now all right let's
get back to the tips don't use the first
few minutes upon waking as the signal of
whether or not you got a good night's
sleep sleep inertia is a real thing in
fact if you sleep a radically short
amount of time you might wake up even
easier but that doesn't mean you had
quality sleep in fact after repaying
some sleep debt you may feel groggier
after a night of proper sleep signaling
that you still need to make up more
hours of sleep the next day sorry bear
pets out of the bed we've seen it time
and time again in research article after
research article pets interrupt our
sleep allow them to hang out in your
bedroom just not directly in that bed
pay attention to noise while a silent
room can be great for a good night's
sleep you can have white noise in your
room and still sleep great and you don't
have to get an expensive white noise
machine you can just turn on YouTube or
maybe have a fan in the corner all work
through the same principle essentially
you want to have a consistent same
volume of noise because what happens
then is your brain begins to tune out
that noise just like it would as if it
were silent make your bedroom pitch
black get blackout curtains put Shades
up do whatever it is you have to do to
eliminate all light from your sleeping
environment there's been studies that
show even a candle flickering in the
corner of your room can impact the
quality of your sleep for safety reasons
I do say maybe have a motion activated
light somewhere in your room so that if
you do get up in the middle of the night
to use the bathroom you'll still be safe
go to sleep when you're tired it may
sound simple but at the same time it's
easy to push through the sleepiness at 9
pm when you're binging your favorite
Netflix show but if you missed that
crucial window you may get a second wind
and find it hard to fall asleep until
really late at night modern day devices
have sleep modes on them to prevent your
friends drunk texting you and waking you
in the middle of the night my
recommendation here is to customize
those alerts to allow certain contacts
in your phone to be able to contact you
any time of night also it allows you to
set a specific number of calls that will
bypass the sleep mode system so that if
your father or your friend calls you two
three times that might mean it's an
emergency and it should still ring to
wake you unless you want to wake up with
a sore back or sore neck in the morning
avoid having cold air blown directly on
you this could mean turning the fan away
the air conditioner away or closing a
window because direct cooling onto your
skin can over cool an area thereby
decrease circulation to a muscle causing
a spasm to occur keep your feet warm but
not sweaty it's easy to put on a really
thick sock and then your feet are
sweating and causing potential fungal
infections to form instead what you want
to do is optimize it so that they're
warm the blood vessels vasodily meaning
open up and that will signal to your
brain that it's comfortable to fall
asleep this one is going to sound weird
if after 15 minutes you can't fall
asleep get out of bed because the last
thing you want to do is toss and turn
building up that anxiety of why you
can't fall asleep instead what you want
to do is leave that bed leave the
bedroom do something relaxing wait until
you get sleepy then get into the bed
because then you will associate the bed
with sleep as opposed to suffering
because you can't sleep get that
exercise because physical exercise
improves the quality and duration of
your sleep in fact it's that moderate
intensity aerobic exercise that improves
your deep sleep your slow wave sleep
where your brain and body have a chance
to rejuvenate some say don't exercise
too close to bedtime I think you need to
do what works for you for me I try and
stay away from that high intensity
exercise close to bedtime avoid alcohol
before bedtime while it may help you
fall asleep it's actually going to hurt
the quality of your sleep even just
having a couple drinks can hurt your
ability to enter and stay in REM sleep
that's that restorative sleep that you
need in order to function well
throughout the day no matter how
tempting it is be careful with long-term
use of sleep aid medications whether
we're talking about prescription or
over-the-counter they do have legitimate
risk anxiety is one of the most common
complaints I hear from patients as to
why they can't get good sleep I
constantly suffer with insomnia because
I'm tired but wired in those cases I do
say it's smart to talk to your doctor
about potentially starting therapy or
maybe even the medication but for me
what a little strategy that worked quite
well is the three good things before
getting into bed writing down old paper
and Pen three good things that happened
to you that day and the reasons as to
why they happen this allows your mind to
take a break from thinking about the
negative nervousness that it constantly
feels in order to keep you safe and
instead think about the positive
emotions and let that gratitude guide
you into getting a proper night's sleep
in the evening begin to dim your lights
just as it's important to expose
yourself to Bright Light in the morning
you need to dim the lights in the
evening this is strictly for your
circadian rhythm if you have exposure or
bright light in the evening your
circadian rhythm gets thrown off your
melatonin production starts to crease
and your sleepiness begins to float away
was that too dramatic huge thanks to
Mattress Firm for sponsoring this video
shop their dreamsember sale to give
yourself or your loved ones a gift for
better sleep as always stay happy and
healthy
[Music]